Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in the chapter of patience,
the 26th consecutive narration.
And now
says,
We already spoke about
and his father in detail in the previous
narrations
that some of the
needy from amongst the Ansar, the
companions
The Ansar, the people of Medina, they
came to the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam. They were in need of financial
help. So they came to him and asked him
and he gave them
and then they asked him again on another
occasion and he gave them
or they asked him on the same occasion.
meaning that they asked him for help. He
helped them. They said we need some more
you know increase us. So he obliged
and this continued
until he didn't have anything else left
to give.
And then he said to them after he had
given them everything that he had to
give,
there is nothing that I have hidden,
nothing that I own or possess
that I could possibly give you or
help you with that I would hide from
you.
Yet whoever attempts modesty and
whoever attempts to not ask, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will suffice him.
Is to attempt
being sufficed.
You're in need, but you try to
push on without asking. You try your
best to
exhibit sufficiency.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam teaches
us some of the most important lessons
here. These three statements he is going
to say. I hope that we all take them to
heart. he says,
these are the three statements he made
to them. He said, "Whoever attempts
modesty or whoever attempts
self-sufficientness,
being self-sufficient,
Allah will make him self-sufficient."
When we say self-sufficient,
meaning not in need or in dire need of
other human beings, we don't mean that a
person, you know, is said in in
popular culture today, you know, believe
in yourself and love yourself and all
this nonsense that doesn't make any
sense really. This is not what we're
talking about. self-sufficient
meaning that a person needs only Allah
that a person is able to rely on Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala alone that a person
is not in need of extending his hand to
others right if a person is in need of
his brothers then there is no shame
in that and his brothers are obligated
by Allah to pull him out of whatever
difficulty he is In however a person
attempts
modesty, modesty in asking
and whoever tries to be self-sufficient,
Allah will suffice him.
And whoever tries to be patient, Allah
will make him patient. And this is the
reason he put this narration in this
chapter.
The wording here, the structure of the
word
right in Arabic articulates
trial and error articulates practice.
Whoever tries to practice patience,
Allah will make him patient.
So why didn't he tell them this before
he gave them?
Because
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam said
the veins of the human being just like
his own blood.
The most destructive
or one of the most destructive of things
is suspicions of your Muslim brother,
your Muslim sister.
Person may say, well, come on. How could
they be suspicious of the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam? This is the
point. The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam is trying to not give a shan
any foothold to not give him any
chance to whisper. They come to him.
Imagine this scenario. They come to him
to ask for some help and then he starts
telling them about being patient. Right?
A person may get the idea that he's just
he doesn't want to help us. That's why
he's telling us all of this, right? He's
making it seem this is for our
good, but it's just cuz he doesn't want
to help us. Obviously, his companions
were much better than that. But in
previous nations, many of the
followers of Misam, of
the prophets before, they were harmed by
their people in this exact way. And so
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
in order to teach them this lesson he
gave them everything he had first
he first gave them everything he had
then when there were nothing left to
give he said if I had anything else I
wouldn't hide it from you however
whoever attempts modesty Allah will make
him modest and whoever attempts to be
sufficient Allah Allah will make him
sufficient and whoever tries to be
patient Allah will make him patient. Now
the lesson is learned and so this
statement here whoever tries to be
patient
Allah will make him patient. This gives
us a feeling of trying a feeling of
practice and that's correct. Patience
any other discipline and Islam in
general. The practices of Islam
and patience specifically,
they are a discipline. You have to
practice them. And the more you practice
them, the better you get. And any
discipline once you reach a level of
skill,
you can lose that skill and it can
regress if you don't continue to
practice it.
It It's not you reach there and
then that's it. You're at the summit,
you're fine, you'll be there for the
rest of your life. No. No. If you don't
continue to practice,
you will lose your progress and you will
lose that skill and the blade of your
patience will become dull. Right? So
patience,
modesty,
sufficient,
you know, being sufficient, these are
things that a person has to practice. If
we were looking into the other
narrations also this is mentioned
with knowledge this is mentioned with
forbearance
right these same things that are to be
practiced.
So patience for instance becoming upset
or being offended or reaching out
for help when you could push yourself
a little bit further. whatever the
situation is, right? Being patient, it
is something that you practice and build
up, right? And it takes time and you're
going to you're going to fail a lot just
any skill. When you first begin,
you fail
10 times out of 10 or nine times out of
10, but you're conscious of the failure
now. And then you continue to practice,
continue to practice, and now you fail
only nine times out of 10. Now you fail
only eight times out of 10. Seven, six,
five. Now your skill is building up.
Half of the time you do it, half of the
time you fail. You continue to practice
and practice until you're able to not
fail 10 times out of 10. And now you
have to continue to practice in order to
retain that discipline and skill.
And whoever attempts patience and tries
to be patient, Allah will make him
patient.
Subhan Allah.
Wasamuhammed.